[Music]
on this Thursday night Canada's spy
Chief sounds the alarm about foreign
meddling foreign interference is
therefore complex and enduring threat to
Canada sovereignty why the prime
minister is resisting calls for a public
inquiry
a deadly Avalanche near the Alberta BC
border be the saddest day ever the
victims all from Germany leaving
communities in two countries in mourning
Doctors Without planetary borders
there's no Canadian jurisdiction in
outer space the rise of space tourism
raising legal questions about Aerospace
medicine
plus ancient Secrets Unearthed what's
been hiding beneath the Great Pyramid of
Giza
[Music]
International with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight Jeff Semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us opposition MPS are now officially
calling on the federal government to
launch a public inquiry into allegations
of foreign interference together they
passed a non-binding motion tonight on
the same day the Canada's spy Chief was
called to testify on Parliament Hill
cease's director David vignon described
the Chinese Communist party as the
principal threat facing Canada's
Democratic institutions specifically
pointing to the activities of the ccp's
overseas arm known as the united front
work department
the budget of the organization dedicated
to engage uh the the Chinese abroad but
also to interfere in in other countries
Internal Affairs that done by the FWD
the budget of that organization now is
bigger than their entire department of
Foreign Affairs it gives you a sense of
how important this is this is why
um the president of China Gigi ping
calls the ufwd one of its magic weapons
today's testimony from top federal and
security officials in the House of
Commons shed light on some
investigations into alleged interference
but it did nothing to quell the calls
for a full inquiry Mackenzie gray has
tonight's top story
The Hunt is on inside cesus to find who
leaked highly classified allegations of
Chinese foreign interference and
Canada's top spy suggested those
whistleblowers were unsatisfied with
prime minister Justin Trudeau's handling
of Beijing any information that is
undisclosed uh uh in a unauthorized way
uh you do not know the consequences you
cannot foresee the consequences down the
road so I think it's it's very serious
through a combination of intelligence
sources and thesis documents Global News
first reported that the Chinese
Consulate in Toronto allegedly bust in
Canadian Chinese seniors and Chinese
International students to vote for
current liberal MP Han dong during his
2019 nomination meeting in Don Valley
North dong in the Liberal Party of
Canada deny the allegations but sources
say ceases warned senior Liberal Party
of Canada staff about Dawn today David
Vino would not comment on the
allegations but did say he briefed the
Prime Minister on interference more
broadly I have had many opportunities to
brief the Prime Minister cabinet and
different ministers on the subject of
National Security including specifically
on foreign interference that
interference video believes
disproportionately impacts Chinese
diaspora the threat does not come from
the Chinese people but rather from the
Chinese Communist party and the
government of China
indeed we are keenly aware that Chinese
communities are often the primary
victims of PRC foreign interference
efforts in Canada one of those alleged
Chinese interference efforts appears to
be blunted does that mean that the
operations from those illegally illegal
uh Beijing police stations have ceased
we are our understanding is they've
assist and we're continuing
investigation of the ongoing complaints
of foreign interference have inundated
the commissioner of Canada elections
recently Carolyn Samar testifying her
office received 174 complaints about
foreign meddling in the 2019 and 2021
votes most of those complaints have been
resolved but smart says a few are still
open this review is ongoing as I speak
to determine whether there's any
tangible evidence of wrongdoing under
the Canada elections act NDP
conservative and Block members of the
House committee studying in foreign
interference voted to ask the government
to establish a public inquiry on the
issue the Liberals voted against the
non-bonding motion but in the end Jeff
the decision to call an inquiry is up to
the prime minister
Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thanks Mac
and let's bring in our David Aiken now
to unpack some of the political
implications in all of this so David
help us understand why the prime
minister is resisting calls for this
full public inquiry what's the downside
well Jeff you know the Prime Minister
would argue he has not yet ruled out a
public inquiry but liberals have been
arguing that multiple processes are
already underway to tighten election
security the government is considering
recommendations for example from the
chief electoral officer and there were
some recommendations in that report
earlier this week that talked about
major interference or lack of it in the
2021-1 2021 election now finally the
prime minister's office pointed out that
it doesn't seem to make much sense to
have a public inquiry when the top
secret stuff that's the important stuff
cannot be made public and in fact that
is a point that the director of thesis
made today
how can we find the best possible way of
having classified information you know
uh part of of a of a classified
discussion but uh inform the proper
debate without becoming public is that
the key conundrum I can under indeed so
Jeff I'll answer your question by
echoing a famous phrase of another
Canadian Prime Minister this PM believes
an inquiry if necessary but not
necessarily an inquiry yes I'll take
former Prime Minister Mackenzie King for
500 thanks David and the opposition
parties of course as we've heard all
seem to agree that there should be a
public inquiry but they've disagreed
over exactly what it should look like so
what were the sticking points yeah so
the original motion to have an inquiry
came from the new Democrats and the NDP
and they wanted a pretty broad inquiry
but they definitely wanted the spotlight
on liberals and conservatives and
conservatives do not want any part of
the spotlight they want the focus on
China the Liberals and prime minister
Trudeau now the director of thesis once
again he's got no opinion on the
proposed inquiry but he made the case
that the issue of foreign interference
is not limited to any one party any one
election or even any one jurisdiction
the actors were engaging for
interference against Canadians do so at
all levels of government at the federal
provincial and Municipal level and
they're doing it across party lines
and it is that scope of the interference
Jeff that makes it such an important
issue David Aiken in Ottawa thanks David
turning to western Canada now and
another deadly Avalanche in British
Columbia three skiers from Germany died
in yesterday's slide bringing the total
number of people killed this season to
12.
at least 10 hella skiers were caught up
in the Avalanche Southwest of Invermere
near Panorama Mountain Resort that's
about a three-hour drive from Calgary
Jamie Dahl reports
foreign
the Choppers just keep on coming landing
at the Invermere hospital as horrified
neighbors watch on just sadness just
going you know this is tragic some you
know this is this is not a good scenario
I knew that there had was something very
wrong you know so I let some candles and
you know it says some prayers ten people
swept up in a Class III Avalanche
Wednesday while Holly skiing outside of
Panorama BC three skiers all from the
same Village in Bavaria Germany died the
mayor of that town writing in a
statement all of us in our community are
deeply shocked by this accident and we
feel deep sorrow I myself am shocked
stunned I still cannot believe how cruel
life can be he's not the only one
feeling that way r.k haliskey the
company involved says it's devastated be
the saddest day ever not just in our
lives but
definitely here at RK for the tragedy
that's taken place for others including
a guide were injured that are expected
to recover anytime
one of your team members goes down it's
tragic again this is the most difficult
day of my life
unstable snowpack this season
halted in multiple deadly Avalanches
prompting countless warnings there's a
layer at the bottom of the snowpack that
continues to be a concern for us and has
continued to produce a large and
destructive skier and Rider triggered
Avalanches risk conditions were
considerable at the time of the slide RK
says it has served 160 000 clients since
1970 and is committed to safety this is
what we are trained to do as guides as
an organization
as team members as Pilots we go through
thorough thorough training the company
has asked heli Canada to activate a
critical incident stress management team
to help them navigate This Disaster
sending their support to the families
who now have the overwhelming task of
getting the bodies of their loved ones
home Jamie Dahl global news near
invermir British Columbia
Britain's spy agency is being blasted in
a new report looking into the 2017
Manchester Arena bombing an inquiry
found National Security and
counter-terrorism officials missed a
significant opportunity to act on key
information that might have prevented
the suicide attack a radicalized
extremists detonated a homemade bomb at
an Ariana Grande concert killing 22
people the youngest just ate
forgiveness will never be an option for
such evil intentions and those that
played any part in the murder of our
children will never ever get forgiveness
it was the deadliest Terror plot on
British soil since the 2005 London
bombings Crystal commencing Reports on
the inquiry's findings and Lessons
Learned
Atkins the lives of thousands were
altered there was a realistic
possibility that actionable intelligence
could have been obtained which might
have led to action preventing the attack
actionable intelligence by UK
counter-terrorism and National Security
officials on this man Solomon abidi
abidi detonated a bomb in the Manchester
arena in May of 2017. he killed 22
people and injured more than 200. in his
final report the inquiry chair concluded
the attacker's family had extremist
views and were involved in the quote
struggles in Libya authorities knew of
abidi yet did not question him when he
returned from Libya he was not followed
nor did they recommend him to prevent a
UK de-radicalization program as a result
of these failures at the very least a
real possibility of preventing this
attack was lost
this is a devastating conclusion for us
the majority of evidence and the
recommendations to the security service
is sealed because of National Security
MI5 did make a statement on the few
details made public had we managed to
seize the slim chance we had
those impacted might not have
experienced such appalling loss and
Trauma
I am profoundly sorry
that MI5 did not prevent the attack
forgiveness however is not possible says
Liam Curry's mother from top to bottom
MI5 to the associate of the attacker we
will always believe that you all played
a part in the murder of our children
Parliament has been tasked with ensuring
the secret recommendations to the
security sector are implemented the
mayor of Manchester says it is now
beholden on all public bodies to use the
findings to ensure that all communities
are better prepared to protect people
Crystal gemancing Global News London
the U.S Secretary of State confronted
his Russian counterpart today demanding
Moscow and its war in Ukraine Anthony
blinken and Sergey lavrov met for a
brief private meeting on the sidelines
of the G20 Summit in India it's the
first face-to-face meeting between a U.S
cabinet member and a top Russian
official since the start of the
full-scale invasion but blinken says
Russia isn't budging
President Putin however has demonstrated
zero interest in engaging saying there's
nothing to even talk about
unless and until Ukraine accepts and I
quote the new territorial realities
while doubling down on his brutalization
of Ukraine
meanwhile Ukrainian soldiers are
fighting an intense Russian attack on
the Eastern Front Line residents near
Bak moot are fleeing their homes as
Russia closes in Kiev says enemy forces
are now storming the city bakmut is
considered a key gateway to the
Strategic donbass region
to Greece now where violent protests
erupted in response to that horrific
train crash that killed dozens of people
Tuesday night
protests broke out in multiple Greek
cities late Wednesday many demanding
answers blaming the government and the
train operator for the tragedy two
trains collided head-on at high speed
they've been traveling on the same track
for several kilometers at least 57
people are now confirmed dead a station
manager has been charged with multiple
offenses including manslaughter and
negligence
another American Retailer is closing its
doors in Canada
coming up why Nordstrom is shutting down
[Music]
California has declared a state of
emergency in 13 counties including La as
it digs out from rare extreme winter
storms some areas have been buried in
more than three meters of snow over the
past week officials say it could take 10
days to clear Mountainside communities
another severe storm could hit this
weekend
and staying with the U.S a Pennsylvania
man who booked a flight to Florida has
been arrested after authorities say an
explosive device was found inside his
checked luggage
Mark muffley now faces federal charges
for allegedly trying to bring explosives
fuses and a lighter on board an aircraft
police say he fled the airport before he
was arrested
and a dozen charges have also been laid
after a major explosion that rocked an
Ottawa suburb and injured 12 people last
month
Cody Troy Crosby faces multiple counts
of arson breaking and entering and
criminal negligence causing bodily harm
that blast destroyed four homes under
construction it was initially blamed on
a gas leak
[Music]
finding Health Care in the cosmos next
the legalities around medical treatment
in space
Nordstrom is shutting down all 13 of its
Canadian stores and cutting 2500 jobs
the seattle-based retailer says all
Nordstrom and Nordstrom Rack locations
will close by late June its e-commerce
business is ending today sales and
profits sank for the holiday quarter and
the company says it doesn't think it
will ever be profitable Nordstrom opened
its first Canadian store in Calgary in
2014.
Canada Soccer says it has reached an
agreement in principle with the Women's
National Team on compensation for last
year the details are still to be
finalized but the deal would be similar
to the one for the men's team and would
include pregame incentives and
result-based compensation the sports
governing body called it a step forward
in its ongoing labor dispute with both
teams
space tourism is poised to take off in
the coming years as private companies
embark on sending paying customers to
the stars and researchers are now
exploring how doctors should operate in
the final frontier as Catherine Ward
reports advances in Aerospace medicine
could have implications for Health Care
here on Earth my name is McCoy I'm a
doctor medical support for space flight
is a key part of any Mission both times
I was in space as the physician crew
medical officer I treated my colleagues
most of the time things run according to
plan uh Houston we have a problem but
there is always risk what level of care
do we need to be able to provide on
orbit if something unforeseen happens if
an emergency happens in somebody's ill
or injured
that question even more important as the
space tourism industry becomes more
mainstream we've gone beyond the
regulatory framework of the
international Partners the government
agencies have made up the International
Space Station program and all the
protocols the standards of care the
training requirements medical licenses
are tied to geography once a physician
is licensed to practice in Canada then
they practice in that province with
patients in that Province for Canadian
Physicians who actually want to practice
in space they basically would also have
to to find a way to legally practice in
that jurisdictional boundary which is
space and as flights open up to more
people there is an interesting legal
predicament under international law
outer space
has no jurisdiction so there's no
Canadian jurisdiction in outer space
outer space belongs to all more
flexibility for medical licensing could
be part of the solution can have a
license that can be portable that can be
used for example at any launch facility
in the world with respect to any space
flight participants over whom they're
supposed to oversee with experts noting
that approach could also help right here
at home there's no question there's a
subset of Physicians where we would
benefit significantly in our ability to
deliver virtual clinical care primarily
to patients in Northern Canada if we
were able to get a license in more than
one province
more than one Province and perhaps more
than one Galaxy Catherine Ward Global
News Earth
up next ancient Discovery the first
glimpse of a secret chamber inside one
of the Seven Wonders of the World
[Music]
welcome back now to an astonishing
Discovery out of Egypt where for the
very first time archaeologists were able
to peer inside a secret chamber hidden
in the Great Pyramid of Giza one of the
Seven Wonders of the World until 2015 no
one even knew the chamber existed Mike
Armstrong explains how they found it
as imposing as it is in terms of size
the Great Pyramid is as impressive in
terms of Secrets it was built as a tomb
a monument to the reign of pharaoh Khufu
around 2560 BC
well 4 500 years later it's still making
news we are in front of a major
important
now what experts have been able to do
for the first time is look inside a void
in the pyramid it's an open space
discovered several years ago but only
with scans and radiography they knew it
was there but couldn't see it until this
moment this is the endoscope while this
is the camera of the endoscope Cruz
found a way to slide a wire with the
camera at the end basically between
blocks it was only six millimeters wide
and made it right into the void there
had been speculation the room was a
corridor but now knowing what it looks
like some experts say it may be
something else if we say that this
tunnel is protecting or is holding a
Stones about something we cannot say
it's according at all
there is no way now the chamber is the
shape of a hallway narrow and long about
nine meters from end to end but it
doesn't seem to go anywhere there is a
shaft about seven meters below it so
could there be something in between
there is a theory this void may actually
have been built as an open space to take
weight off something below possibly
another still undiscovered chamber
between the seven meters and and the
tunnel that we found today there is
something important in my opinion this
project brought together experts from
around the world including Laval
University in Quebec City it also
brought together some of the newest
technology available and while it all
helps answer some questions it's also
leading to new ones
Mike Armstrong Global News
and that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Jeff Semple in tonight's
your Canada we pay tribute to
singer-songwriter Joni Mitchell
[Applause]
still got it Mitchell joined a group
performance last night in Washington DC
the 79 year old was honored with the
Library of Congress Gershwin prize for
popular song She's the first Canadian
and the only the third woman to receive
the Accolade thanks for watching hope to
see you back here again tomorrow have a
great night
now
we're captive on the carousel time